absolutely president Orland has declared
a state of emergency he's banned traffic
in certain parts of Paris people are
being urged to stay at home an emergency
meeting is being held tonight sort of
senior ministers as they discuss the
best way to deal with this unprecedented
crisis even worse than the Charlie Hebdo
attacks in in January and the Army has
been mobilized all measures are being
taken to deal with this situation which
was still ongoing the police are saying
that there were at least six shootings
in different parts of Paris and there
were three explosions this evening at
the start of France where Germany and
France were playing a match where
thousands of people were attending and
the reports that we're getting are that
French media are saying that about 40
people have died there are suggestions
that number could rise at least 60 have
been injured and we don't yet know the
motive for these shootings but people
will think back to the Charlie Hebdo
attacks in January in which 17 people
died at the attack at the the Charlie
Hebdo offices and the Jewish live market
and these attacks were carefully
coordinated we don't know yet who was
behind them but they started about a
couple of hours ago
we were getting a report an hour half
ago of a shooting at a restaurant in a
face central part of Paris a very busy
area where a lot of people were
congregating on Friday night and then a
few minutes after that we heard about no
shooting nearby at a bar and where a
concert was going on and there's a
concert venue and we're hearing that
there's an ongoing hostage situation
there and then we heard of the attack on
the stadium north of Paris where the
match was going on between Germany and
France explosions there so a very
confused picture a very alarming picture
and a situation is still unfolding here
in Paris tonight